please welcome bethany frankel everybody
hey well first of all i have to say
congratulations on the engagement news
that's amazing thank you so much nice to
meet you yeah it's nice to meet you too
i had to lead with that that's an
amazing thing so how did you two meet we
met online
oh really on a dating app
are you serious
i am okay i heard all my girlfriends are
listening right now because everybody
doesn't think that's gonna pan out
that's amazing look at you you're like a
poster child for it's gonna work it's
gonna work it's it's it's a good way to
do it i mean the truth is you're sort of
deciding what you want and when you're
ready and you take it seriously and you
can sort of vet people and you meet
people on zooms and you can see where
they live and how they live do they have
dogs what you know you can get a whole
sense of someone without having to leave
your house you don't leave your house
until it's really worth it yeah i love
that okay you post a lot of unfiltered
photos which i love um why do you think
that's important i think it's important
for people to see
personally i think it's important for
especially little boys little girls to
see like this is not normal i have a
team of people that did all this today
you know and that's not how i wake up
well
when i was growing up it was
mademoiselle and cosmopolitan and those
magazines and you know you would hear
somebody say something about airbrushing
but you didn't really understand it but
at least they were models and you kind
of got a sense that that was a photo
shoot but now it's just regular people
that look nothing like their photos and
it's effectively lying you have to let
people know i mean i'll post i'm in hair
and makeup now because 95 of my life i'm
in pajamas i don't love hair i don't
like makeup i don't like i like being
healthy my daughter is very free and
earthy and natural and she likes that so
i don't know if it's because she sees me
all the time not made up but i feel a
responsibility to post authentic
accurate pictures of me because it's not
fair for people to feel bad about
themselves it's literally a zero-sum
game making ourselves feel good by
posting inaccurate pictures of ourselves
makes other people feel badly because i
spoke to my assistants who are 24 and 25
and they feel self-conscious if they
don't post a picture of them that's
filtered or face tuned or not who they
really are so that can't be good because
if you want to just be who you are and
be proud
everybody else is doing it so now you're
the only person looking natural so it's
a responsibility to be honest about who
you are where you are in your life and
your process and
share the information yeah no absolutely
i
i don't wear makeup so often that my
kids freak out if i come home because i
have a shower here so most times i
shower here and if i come home and i
haven't showered here at work and i get
home and i have makeup on my boy will be
like what's wrong with your face why is
your face like he freaks out because i
don't wear makeup ever unless i'm
working um but congrats i want to to
switch over to this congrats on your
entrepreneur cover what does that mean
to you um it's a good segue because that
is a cover that many people commented
wow thanks for showing what you really
look like i'm a 50 year old woman i mean
i'm obviously dressed in hair makeup
that day but i don't look like some doll
and it's a business story about um an
interesting woman who has started from
the bottom and created a success uh with
a team but you know basically on my own
and uh i love that
it's never lost on me these amazing
moments when you're on the cover of such
a major business magazine it's about
being interesting it's not about being
the hottest most beautiful person in the
world it's about having a story you can
inspire other people
uh who have an idea or may not be a
traditional business person or may not
be a corporate person but they have an
idea where they have that work ethic and
there's so many ways
to be successful so many ways to make it
so i just think that it's a good story
to tell not just because it's me but
it's a i'm a woman who started later too
so i i didn't have any sort of success
until my late 30s so you could be a mom
you could have kids you could be a
single strongly mom and still
go all the way yeah i love that that's
so inspiring it's
empowering um can you tell everybody
about your your new show though the big
shot with bethany so the big shot with
bethany is a modern
version of the apprentice where it's
about real business real brands it's
about me as a person meaning you're
seeing me warts and all and how i'm
holding this business together often
with scotch tape it comes from a genuine
need where i need my second in command
and it's a very different show it's very
unexpected it's showing the truth of my
business that it's hard that i hold it
together that i work like an animal
and that i need somebody to be my second
to take off some of the pressure and
it's all totally real and it's based on
my businesses versus just manufactured
projects and tasks integrations it's not
it's actually things that are happening
in the world
within my business you are so impressive
thank you so much it's so nice to have
you on the show but also just to meet
you oh so nice to meet you thank you so
much so funny at the beginning of the
pandemic my daughter and i were singing
stronger like that was sort of an anthem
and just singing it so right before you
came on i said to friends you want to
meet kylie clarkson and i said she's the
one who you know sings stronger she's
like oh because you know she's all over
tick tocks she is impressed
[Music]
you